identifica los conjuntos de líneas
paralelas y líneas perpendiculares de la
siguiente imagen es lo que dice aquí y
solo como un recordatorio dos líneas son
paralelas y están en el mismo plano y
jamás se intersectan entonces aquí
estamos en el mismo plano el plano de la
pantalla ahora una manera para verificar
esto por ejemplo aquí parece parece que
estas dos líneas se van a interceptar en
algún punto pero no podemos pasarnos
simplemente en la imagen para saber eso
porque debes tener algo de información
ya sea información en el dibujo o el
enunciado por ejemplo esa información
está aquí aquí tú puedes ver que la
línea st y la línea v ambas intersectan
a la línea cede formando ángulos rectos
cuando la cortan y si tú tienes dos
líneas que cortan una tercera en un
mismo ángulo formando un mismo ángulo
estos son llamados ángulos
correspondientes
estos son ángulos correspondientes y si
eso pasa si tienes ángulos
correspondientes entonces
estas líneas la línea s t la línea v son
paralelas podemos usar la notación esta
anotación la línea s tm ponemos las
flechas indicando que son líneas y los
segmentos así que la línea s t es
paralela paralela a la línea v así que
bueno yo creo que terminamos con las
líneas paralelas aquí son el único
conjunto de líneas paralelas que están
en este diagrama entonces ahora pensemos
en las líneas perpendiculares son las
líneas perpendiculares son las que se
intersectan en un ángulo de 90 grados
forman un ángulo de 90 grados a la hora
de interceptar se entonces por ejemplo
la línea s t la línea de s t es
perpendicular a la línea c de y sabemos
esto porque cortan en un ángulo de 90
grados nos dieron esa información con
esta cajita esta cajita indica que la
medida de ese ángulo de 90 grados y
usando este mismo argumento la línea 1
es perpendicular a la línea cede ahora
tengo que especificar que estas son
líneas
así que la línea v es perpendicular a la
línea cd&v y este ambas son
perpendiculares a cdm luego tenemos más
información donde dos líneas se
intersectan en un ángulo de 90 grados un
ángulo recto son la línea ave y w x así
que ab es definitivamente perpendicular
a w x ajam este es perpendicular a la
línea w x y bueno ya listo terminamos
aquí ya tenemos el conjunto de líneas
perpendiculares líneas paralelas así que
bueno ahora que algo bien importante a
bs de no son bueno al menos no parece
que se corten en un ángulo recto pero
bueno claro hasta que no son paralelas
tampoco son paralelas porque parece ser
que están a punto están a punto de
cortarse como lo puedes ver aquí bueno
al menos eso parece en el dibujo o por
ejemplo si nos dicen que se corta aquí
en un ángulo recto podríamos decir que
que quizás si son perpendiculares a b y
c de o decir que son paralelas pero
bueno no porque eso sería como algo muy
bizarro en nada parece ser que son
paralelas
de hecho terminarán siendo para
otras líneas porque si estuviese cajita
aquí pero bueno bueno no lo está y eso
es muy sería muy extraño que lo
estuviera porque no parece un ángulo
recto pero basándonos esta información
ya sabemos cuáles son los conjuntos de
líneas paralelas y líneas
perpendiculares así que nos vemos pronto